on va vous faire caler olivier une
interview à l'américaine donc j'essaye
elle est belle soirée we can
comment avez vous reçu le scénario du
film
c'est à dire que c'était un soir chez
moi ça a frappé à la porte
c'était un bonnet un poney qui frappé à
ma porte et sur le dos du codé il y
avait un scénario de t'accrocher avec
avec du scotch
le poney est reparti sans dire au revoir
et c'est là que j'ai compris que les
quads et ne parlez pas oui d'accord
je crois qu'à que c'est le premier film
que vous faites en france pourquoi
accepter de tourner en france de tous
mais d'autres carrier enfants vous savez
j'ai déjà essayé tourner dans différents
pays du monde
on va refuser alors j'ai dit et la
belgique liechtenstein le luxembourg
ce viatique l'italie et surtout les
réalisateurs avec qui j'ai travaillé on
dit seule chose ils m'ont dit tu es
vraiment à chier
alors je suis arrivé en france et aux
gens sauraient dit vas-y vas-y hallassou
de ton film
alors qu'adp merci d'être avec nous
merci d'être avec nous ce soir et
d'avoir choisi tout le monde en parle
pendant le tournage qu'est ce qui vous a
le plus manqué est ce que la production
a assuré sur les [ __ ] et la drogue
vous savez sur le tournage ne devions
pas loin aux prostituées à la drogue
par contre nous avions des poupées
gonflables que nous avions le droit de
nous gonfler trois quatre fois par jour
mais à la plage de la coupe nous avions
et bateaux des petits lui oui
concasser convertir et
c'était vraiment très bon et je me suis
vraiment éclaté et j'adore la france
pour sa part si la pensée j'adore votre
émission
car en tant qu'américain à paris comment
avez vous vécu l'opposition qui a eu
entre la france et les etats-unis au
sujet de la guerre d'irak
un roi qui handicape un job chez vous
savez j'ai vécu aux états unis j'ai
quarante mille têtes de bétail j'habite
dans le wisconsin que les états unis je
connais bien d'ailleurs premier prix
dans ses hamburgers et vous c'est une
fausse question c'est un faux problème
l'opposition entre la france et les
états unis jeudi c'est tout ça pousse
emma nous a tous fait rien avant d'être
français ou américains meccano je décèle
un 1e et j'ai un accent est ce que ce
que vous parlerai aux français vous fric
joue mais joe jeu tout
ouais n'ouvre est très lourd est le vrai
louvre est le vrai bordeaux comme en
jetons
o en levrette you mean to johnny
hallyday oui johnny hallyday johnny
hallyday ya tjrs religieux messieurs le
fils saad el mechri et ces femmes et la
rose au sérieux hier jean paul rodier
chardard brouillage saba il ya tout le
monde allez voir sur le toit
mais qui a tué pamela